across this small gap an enormous
voltage is being
applied glowing arcs appear like tiny
lightning strikes then a blinding light
and an incredible heat
plasma what you're seeing is hotter than
the surface of the Sun and too bright to
look directly at it's hot enough to melt
haum carbonitride the substance with the
highest melting point known to science
but more importantly this plasma is
stable and uniform across a wide area
and that has never been achieved
before the new method could change the
way that certain materials are made and
revolutionize high temperature material
physics if you want to create extreme
heat making a plasma is a good way to go
about it plasma is a straight substance
known as the fourth state of matter
after solid liquid and gas it's a
flowing mass of charged particles that
can be incredibly hot and it's actually
not that hard to make if you apply a
large enough voltage across a gas the
electrons can separate from their atoms
and start to flow across the voltage
Gap the gas becomes ionized and the
rapidly moving charged particles emit
heat and light think of bit like a
lightning strike except instead of
discharging All That Power Engineers can
keep the current flowing and use the
heat that it's creating this is what's
happening inside a plasma cutter or in
plasma arc welding but the researchers
behind this new system wanted to be able
to create more than a single dancing
lightning like Arc their new design is
all about creating as stable a plasma as
possible it works by applying a voltage
between these hairy looking Blocks made
made of thin carbon
fibers each of these microscopic carbon
hairs acts as a tip through which
electrons can flow and with so many
hairs close together all of the gas
between the blocks argon in this case
turns into plasma at stable uniform
temperatures of up to nearly 8,000 de
C these are the kinds of environments
used to make certain materials for
example for jet engine turbine blades
which have to endure extreme ex forces
at high
temperatures this new process could
replace existing methods for Mass
producing these
materials these are also the kinds of
temperatures used by specialist physics
labs to create and experiment with new
kinds of materials only now the
researchers behind this work say you
won't need extremely specialist kit
anymore as their new design can be
easily recreated in Labs all around the
world and that could mean a lot more
experiment mentation with extremely high
temperature materials made using
plasma